I want to pull up this uh this story
right here that's a story I want to look
at this email that you you've uh shown
me yeah the daily wire tried pouching
one of your employees and what would
make this significant is if this
happened after yes your negotiations
okay so so after you're talking about
it's not the first time that this has
happened
after you were talking with the daily
wire about potentially doing a deal yeah
they reach out to your employees and I'm
I'm looking at the email right here
saying that you know they came across
the social media manager hey they got a
great opportunity to join the new
counterculture it says they emailed your
staff and said come work for us instead
right that doesn't not sound like
something a friend would no and the only
reason I'm showing you that is I'm not
going to be showing receipts from third
parties who are who are blameless
victims right Gary said you can show
that he came right to me and said hey
look this came up I said hey they'll
probably offer you more money and I'll
write you a letter of recommendation he
said no I know you guys want to be
monetized
um and uh the issue that took place in
the conversation it might even be the
one you sell where I said like they're
like well you know we do have a social
media department so I got you know we
could do it here that was the one thing
that we talked about maybe splitting I
think at some point and I said I have
Gary and he's awesome so he was he was
named how long after you did that call
about the term sheet did they send this
email
I don't know the day I know it was
definitely after the talks completely
fell through so here's I mean you
probably have the time about what
happened is there was a week where the
election happened right Rumble uh
because we were banned from YouTube
going into the election which I'm sure
was a chance just happenstance uh and
then
um we did that and I thought I was
really kind of securing the future you
know for my children I'm like okay there
are other players in this space people
kind of know I'm a free agent our
performance on Election night is going
to be big because last time it was the
biggest selection stream ever right it
was like 16 17 million people across the
platforms we're only doing it on Rumble
so I wanted to do that and I was really
nervous Kate went well then I did uh two
shows at the the Ryman the original
Grand old Opry yeah in Nashville
and some daily wire people came out and
the shows went really well I mean people
need you know eventually releases
special but if people need to see
comments yeah standing out to both shows
and Dave was earned did fantastically
well too and you think okay you can't do
any better Reuben no no just just me and
Dave oh Dave Linda Dave Landau yeah yeah
yeah right no no yeah yeah I guess yeah
with uh Peterson yeah Landau
um and then he gave me that look no no I
was like I was very confused I thought
that there were hallucinogens in here
from right now because that's the first
thing yeah
it wasn't in there yeah
after that we had those conversations
about like this these are the sticking
points right and please like we also one
but we got to figure out a better way to
do this because it stifles the movement
after that it was yeah we're not going
to be able to come to any kind of terms
and that was for sure after that
conversation I made one fine yeah one
final play in that called like just prom
take me off the table promise me you
won't do it to other people and the
question is
look did you was your understanding when
you invest money when you subscribe was
your understanding that all conservative
Talent out there nearly all
are penalized if they're demonetized was
that your understanding was that your
understanding that then they are
penalized if they are suspended then
they are penalized if they don't take as
many lives was that your understanding
when you were investing in people going
out there and fighting for you because I
know the feedback that I get at these
live shows with thousands of people at
every event and it's not a hard-earned
dollar that I take lightly people feel
powerless they say there's only so much
they can do at least that guy can go out
and fight for me I'd like it to be these
guys and girls and for context too it's
very important these fees pertain to
strikes and Bannings on the major big
Tech platforms right irrespective of
your viewership on the Alternatives
we're all trying our subscribership or
subscribers or sponsors and it's
demonetization too
here's here's an important picture it
should be painted a lot of people are
saying you know Crowder you recorded uh
Jeremy that's not what friends do
they're surprised by it but here's
here's what I'm seeing now and uh you
know putting myself in the middle of
this
you you're always in the middle of it of
course that's what I do right but but
look you you go to the doctor no no your
term sheet okay you go to the Daily wire
they say here's a term sheet you go whoa
this is crazy hey you can't do this the
daily wire then says all of a sudden
you're not also but a few months later
Crowder register stop VidCon then he
calls and secretly records Jeremy he was
setting us up this email right here
paints a different picture in that you
talked with the daily wire and said
here's our issue here's what we can't do
and they said okay and then sometime
later they try no they said if that's
the issue this is our business model and
you don't know business but then they
try and poach one of your employees one
of your and that could be an accident
but it's not the first time yeah well
but you said you didn't you didn't
mentioned him by name and Gary yeah
employee poaching is considered
vulture-ish as it is but it is business
and by the way there's a huge difference
between employees reaching out to you in
a company right and you feel that you're
available which is hap which happens
versus going to someone who is clearly
not available who was mentioned by name
saying this guy is awesome and curious
hilarious because he's Russian he was
born and raised in Russia until he was
13 but he seems totally American no
accent but then occasionally you realize
like he'll say something out of context
like I can kill two birds and get stoned
or something that's me
but I'm polish are we raised in Poland
yes okay so there you go no one would
guess so those first few years did you
have those disconnects where people are
like are you not and you're like I I
don't understand whatever first few
years he still does it I still do it all
the time yeah all the time that's the
point I'm trying to make uh the the
picture painted so far was that you all
of a sudden sent this plan to get the
daily wire and they were blindsided by
it but it actually seems like now now
there was a bit of a back and forth in
that you said hey guys I don't like this
then they say well that's a business
then they try to poach one of your
employees then you're like okay this is
it sounds like it's been going on for
years but but everyone in the space
knows it everyone in this space knows it
this is not an issue of they had a
polite conversation with you said we're
sorry we disagree and then you devised a
plan to come after him there was no then
the daily wire comes and tries to poach
an employee then you guys are like these
kind of business practices can't
continue no and it was always about the
terms and it's it's stupid to say that
this was our plan to get subscribers I'm
sorry like I get a little bit pissed off
with this because that means that you
didn't pay any attention at all to mug
Club forever that was us getting in
touch with our subscribers and making
sure that whatever home we went to on
our own with somebody else we were going
to have access to the people that paid
for our content this was not a plan that
was hatched to make sure that we could
write off into freedom and do whatever
the hell we wanted with this really
great email list it would be it would be
the hardest waiting for that we said it
yeah it was clear and you saw the
numbers there it sounds like you guys
are like right on the precipice of
creating your own network or your own
website where people pay you 10 bucks a
month and just get access and I really
don't want to have to do that like
here's the thing right wouldn't you
wouldn't it be great if you could link
arms with the self-professed most
powerful people on our side we're
supposedly fighting for us but the
problem is when they say we have no
interest in doing that you go wait hold
on hold on a second here's the good news
I bring Tidings with great joy we can
get just as many viewers on Rumble as
you can on YouTube and by the way stay
on YouTube but just don't punish
conservatives for being demonetized they
go this is the business we know no one
else does I don't want to start a
network if you guys could counter offer
what would be the things you would
counter offer right now what deal would
you guys take from a big company let's
not just say the daily wire let's just
say there's another company what's your
ideal job can take there's a problem I
would take a deal I would have taken a
deal that was less money less money and
more honest uh and more freedom and not
penalizing other people he steps in
because I'm like yeah it sounds like a
good money he's like you don't know what
our expenses are gee I'm like I don't
know Gerald you tell me
I got a lot of different terms that you
would have to negotiate and this has
been the sticking point from the very
beginning and it kind of goes back to
something that you said about Candace
getting these questions
it is just 100 you you don't start with
these terms in the contract again it was
like oh it's a term sheet negotiate of
course we negotiate I've been doing that
I understand that that is part of the
process that's what you do in these
things but if you're going to start
there and we say hey that's not that's
not something that should be in this
movement and you're like well we're not
coming back to the table by the way
after the Ryman we were expecting them
to come back and have changed that and
made an offer that we could then start
negotiating from
that never happened so so this is the
the term sheet right here I've got it
this is that the uh the first one
yeah that that one that was sent I guess
October 5th it says that non-binding
turn confidential it does say the only
one no no no I got I got to point out
for you for you uh Stephen uh it says if
any of the major platforms
uh issue a strike you would have the
fear reduced
it gives it gives examples of the major
platforms are uh I'm assuming that's not
limited too
in which case it looks like they're
basically saying what at their
discretion they determine what a major
platform is yes and then so if Twitter
gave you a suspension they'd dock your
fee by 25 even though Twitter is not a
major driver of platformer host right
you know what the good news is could
have been clarified and put in writing
never was and by the way I said that the
first one because that didn't look like
the daily wire one that you're holding I
was like did you uh somebody else I
don't know that's because I think we did
reader view or some by the way do
me a favor I just need to understand
this because one of the arguments that
was put forth is well this is just a
standard starting point for everybody
okay I don't play those games hold on no
but it's not just it's not just a term
sheet it's not just a term sheet
everybody else that production comes out
of you you knew Stephen well enough to
know that he had his own production team
and therefore the costs would be borne
by him but everything else was just
standard of our our apologies we're
leaving it in there because that was one
of the claims that was made this is just
a standard contract you know negotiating
start point of term sheet that we we
always give to everybody it's like yeah
but you knew Stephen well enough so no
he did all of his production but then
you're saying the rest of that it's a
production company it's a production
house right it's everything it's 25
employees it's just disingenuous guys
it's not real well do they do they do
they not know better or is it dishonest
let me ask you this do you really think
I will say this the only thing I've said
about Ben is Ben is brilliant he's one
of the smartest people I've ever known I
don't care what he says okay I still
hope the best for the guy and by the way
for people out there and I know that
they're anti-semitic people I've not
said there's none of this controlled
opposition I 100 believe that Ben
believes what he says even if we
disagree none of that is taking place
the problem is when you demand that
other people fall into line but do you
really believe for a second that Ben is
so ignorant that he thinks that's 50
million dollars a year in my pocket
basketball money do you think Ben
believes that he knows better yeah he
said that is that honest yeah is that
honest now if someone did that with you
and said Tim pool is a money-grubbing
prick and we offered him in basketball
money and someone came out and called
you a little right and you had and
that literally happened and you had the
ability to say and you and you'd seen
this happen to other people behind the
scenes for years and he said that's not
going to be me you had the ability to
prove that it was verifiably false which
no one is arguing
what are you doing of course granted
you know I think there's a a tactical
difference between us as well in that I
think you play Warrior and I play Rogue
again over your heads but Ian said
they're going like right right right I
do have an original copy of Chrono
triggers dog yes uh
he met a girl who grew up on my block
apparently I have her copy from Super
Nintendo like Star Wars Return of the
gym yes
she didn't speak word of English when I
knew her when she was young yep she's
been holding a while okay it's crazy
small world 30 years my strategy would
have been to to poop on the contract
just being you know totally transparent
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time